yeah okay
we carry feet sipping empathy I know
patience is the key put enough on my
ship for free this is tea we carry feet
Michael make up yo good morning
everybody welcome to the first day of
mate May 1 in the building super excited
to be here hope everybody is doing well
families well I'm ready getting to the
show Dustin on one and twos thank you so
much to us for everything you've been
doing
big big big shout out to my man mozzie
put out a banger of an album last night
I'm gonna join that I shared some of my
Instagram story and Twitter
you don't know mo zzy and making a huge
mistake anyway let's get into the show
you today thanks thanks Joey
how you doing quite well you really well
better now that we're with you so we
know you're a busy guy and we only have
a few minutes we're just gonna hop right
into it that's all good with you so Joey
and I he's 17 or 19 we started our first
media startup last year and we launched
our first podcast it's called the debate
without debate podcast and our sole
mission of that podcast is to end
polarization through conversation just
like we're having right now and so based
off of that our main question to you
today is Gary do you view yourself as a
polarizing figure and if so what are
some of the benefits that you've
received from that um I don't I I do
understand that some people do I am
comfortable speaking my mind about
things I genuinely believe in I'm not
trying to you know I look I think
anybody can be viewed polarizing just on
the fact that we live in a politicized
environment where one opinion that you
actually believe in a nice way may not
jive with somebody else's I I tend to be
more polarizing in the businesses that
I'm in so I get you know a challenge
status quo a lot which people view as
polarizing I view myself as practical
mm-hmm
you know I happen to communicate in a
jersey style that I think you know you
know I think cursing may seem polarizing
high energy and conviction may seem
polarizing not accepting the norms of
society me actually I'm clearly very
polarizing I look I think I think I
think polarizing much like other words
or you know ego incompetence people
think they're the same I think they're
completely different polarizing and
passionately practical I think are very
similar but wildly different and I I
think I'm passionately practical mm-hmm
see cuz as an up-and-coming media star
we find it kind of difficult to cut
through the noise sometimes it seems
like most traditional forms of media or
social media for that matter it kind of
emphasizes this polarizing extreme
nature Gary do you do you think that
there's even a market for non polarizing
content and if so what does that
business model look like on an
applicable scale um there's an ungodly
about a bit I mean you know I haven't
taken the time to really audit things
that you would decide with your
subjective opinions aren't polarizing
but like for every like extreme fox or
CNN or or even me I get that I'm
high-energy I look I think I think
entertainment works and I think
information works and I think you know
entertainment has taken over the news in
a lot of ways and that's led to a lot of
mockery but i you know i'm sure i'm sure
there's scientific journals that have
great b2b businesses that do quite well
there's an ungodly amount of business
people I respect that are not over the
top mary meeker puts out one of the best
you know reports each year on startup
and and BC culture she's not polarizing
by people's standards you know is Sheryl
Sandberg's lean in that polarizing book
for some yes for others no you know I
think people look at production and
think that's part of the polarization
what I mean by that is you know there's
a lot of people articulating incredibly
thoughtful work on YouTube podcasts
medium the press and they're just an
ungodly ungodly amount of good con
10th that comes across very calm and
kind of stick like do you consider at
most of MPR's content polarizing if you
are if you're a Republican hardcore you
may cuz you know like the things are
said but I think in the way it's
delivered is quite calm you know and
does extremely well I'm sure that if you
went through the top 200 podcasts right
now in iTunes you would and click them
all you would agree that half of them
are bombastic Howard Stern
you know the barstool and I think you'd
find half of them are just kind of like
quite mundane and and then the question
becomes is are we judging polarization
on style or substance right and so you
know I think I think for me one of the
things that works is I think I have a
style which oh by the way hampers me in
a lot of environments there's an
enormous amount of people who don't like
me without even having a sense of my
substance they just don't like Jersey
talk and then and that's okay I
understand that I'm empathetic to that
but I think there's always a market for
good stuff and yes this does sizzle sell
steaks yep you know what else
sell steaks delicious [ __ ] steaks
that don't have sizzle mm-hmm
Gary if we could have one last question
given that you've you know you started
your own podcast Gary the audio
experience we love that stuff what would
you do if you had zero pre-existing
social capital you are beta Gary and you
wanted to just launch a podcast you know
a lot of listeners who are interested in
starting again I know they I did it on
February 21st 2006
yeah it's called Wine Library TV and
nine people watched mm-hmm so what what
can you do to grow you know like we just
producing content by being so there's
two things there's there's the biggest
thing that will help you grow is
something that allows you to grow
sustainable which is putting out quality
content and quality content doesn't mean
the production quality means other
people on the other side find you funny
smart interesting entertaining period
and a story there's always ways to be
about your post-production and your
distribution it's called making the
content contextual to the 15 websites
that I talked about [ __ ] every second
of my life listen to the reason I bring
up LinkedIn and tik-tok is because
there's organic reach but that doesn't
mean that if you don't have dollars that
Facebook and Instagram are scary good
the ability to do what I did on Twitter
still exists into twitter search the
words of your subject matter and
literally reply to every human that's on
there are you willing to do it for 14
hours a day like I did for four years
with that with limited results most
people don't have that conviction most
people don't love what they do enough I
don't want people to do things for 14
hours and burn out either put in 3 hours
but most people put in 0 hours after
Joey
most people have put in zero hours of
going into Twitter searching the
conversation and replying to 40 people
zero thank you the people have audacity
and expect that people just gonna follow
them it's audacious very true Gary
pleasure really a pleasure you again see
hope so take care guys audacity
Tanner what's good hey Gary I was gone
it's gone really well in you good good
good
so a little bit of background my dad
started started a karate school when I
was four years old and I grew up
learning the martial arts started
competing and 2014 I won a World
Championship and so my whole life I've
been doing this and I haven't really
figured out how to monetize my skill
well how would you like just like what
comes through your mind on selling it
like how do you think about selling it I
mean I would love to like be on social
media and and just produce content that
way and make money through ads on
YouTube or brand deals or sell
subscriptions or sell merchandise or
start a school prop I mean
the first thing that comes to my mind is
sponsorships ads you know I I have
started to school I'm actually working a
grocery store working at a grocery store
right now like 40 hours and a morning
thank you for being in those front lines
yeah Tanner I mean you could start
making YouTube videos and start getting
ads from the YouTube videos tomorrow
mm-hmm you know when somebody comes to
you and they've never done martial arts
and they've never really worked out like
hey I want to be a black belt mm-hmm
right and even the fact that you just
laughed that way what goes through your
mind immediately because you know your
craft so well is like okay buddy like
and right and like you know people say
to you like they mean it too right like
they rub yeah dude I want to be a black
belt and you're like awesome are you
ready for 15 years yeah that's kind of
what you're saying right now about
monetizing through being an influencer
gotcha like it's [ __ ] work yeah now
you ain't our natural talents yeah
exactly like you know this everybody
wants a short cut in their martial arts
like y'all bro can't I just watch a
bunch of videos [ __ ] like right yeah
yeah you just okay yeah it's a lot of
work bro I've been making content every
single day hard since February 2009
gotcha and and that was after I [ __ ]
worked 15 hours a day being an
entrepreneur in a store for 2009 for 11
years and that was after 22 and that was
after really being in business since I
was four eight years doing baseball
cards I'm making three four thousand two
thousand dollars a weekend selling cards
as a kid and having that skill and that
was after 14 and that was after seven
years of being seven to 14 doing things
like washing cars shoveling driveways
singing Christmas carols for a dollar
starting a mini flea market a mini golf
course in my friend Robby turn ex back
yard
you know jostling yeah
this is [ __ ] 37 years of work in the
making
mm-hmm 37 years going hard not kind of
you know think about how hard you work
door at the grocery store 40 hours that
was three days of my workweek
yeah like hard hard yeah I know I you
know on top of that so I get up at 3:00
in the morning to work at the grocery
store and then once I'm done after that
I'm working on my karate school so it's
like I'm impressed
start putting you videos on YouTube for
sure okay I think tick tock is the
[ __ ] Golden Goose right now yeah I
would I would make two tic TOCs a day
about your karate stuff it will work
you'll be shunned yeah sounds good
awesome talk to you soon thank you gay
take care oh yeah I can okay first off a
huge thank you for you and your
incredible team for motivating people
across the entire world my question
targets primarily young adults so for
the people that chose a different path
in life not the typical nine-to-five
lifestyle but more into passion and
pursuing their passion so I started my
business about six months ago and ever
since the feedback from my parents is
negative and they're not supportive
towards me and it's not easy to really
strive for more so what would you
suggest
to balance that your lifestyle yeah so
what kind of business is it a ballet
business I'm a ballet instructor in
Prague around area a little bit and your
parents think it's too high-risk or your
parents immigrants like what's the push
line yes they're immigrants from and
we're businesspeople they were on the
typical you know nine to five and read
and wonders for the you know being
your own time they think you're in
danger like you're gonna fail and it's
gonna set you back yes it's more of the
safety and it's not as yep so are they
really getting at you or they're not
like how's the car like how combative is
the conversation is a disappointment or
is it even like putting you down and and
do they and and how are you struggling
with it or not really I'm with my
business I'm actually not struggling I
apologize with the feedback with the
feedback because I'm still living under
the same so coming are you
are you able are you able to not do you
have friends that you could slum it with
meaning do you have friends that might
people in - like like the sooner the
better you know that right because it's
gonna be listen I have a lot of empathy
for your parents you know iris I come
from that part of the world as you know
like a lot of people that came from you
know that regime don't have
entrepreneurial spirit because you know
most people don't have entrepreneurial
spirit and the second that system was
based on you know on you know socialism
with the aspiration for communism which
is the state will take care of you and
it goes to be comfortable I think that
you listen you're gonna win this game
I'll tell you why the fact that you're
even here on this you know call means
that you're aware of me you're aware of
an alternative conversation and more
importantly if I didn't exist or anybody
else it's intuitively in you this is the
only way you see it but I don't think
you need to become padded I think one of
the moves that
can do is not be combative with your
parents but actually be empathetic you
know when they're coming at you it's
hard to not you know not to either a be
upset or B go back at that I actually
think the answer might be C which is
being compassionate to them being like
mom and dad I thank you so much for what
you've done for me I understand that
you're only saying this because you're
scared because this is how you see the
world but you have to understand that
even if I fail and then get a job like
you want me to that's what I have to do
otherwise I will resent you and be
unhappy my whole life so I love you for
trying to push me scare me challenge me
into doing what you want me to do for my
life but that's only gonna lead to me
not loving being around you it's gonna
only push us further apart maybe this
fails and I do get the job that you want
me to however I have to do this and I'm
doing this for two reasons
for myself and for you guys because if I
take the [ __ ] job that you want me
to take and at 37 I resent you that I
didn't follow my dream about ballet
that's gonna lead to a bad relationship
between us have you and listen you know
I'm telling you this with somebody that
understands so be a DNA like like I
actually think the ultimate strength the
ultimate like push against that hard
pressure is compassion and empathy I
don't think so because the because it's
still gonna be in the air just because
you're not there you may not have to
hear it as much but it's not gonna lead
to peace they still genuinely fear you
doing something like this have you told
them that you're empathetic and
compassionate to them or have you gone
quiet where have you got combative or
have you gone like what's been your
reaction to them mostly just why
I don't really communicate with them at
all because not gonna help me it's it's
just gonna like bring me down it's
nothing
positivity is just not really good and
do they and do they understand that
you're like distancing yourself yeah and
how are they what is that making them do
who's more who's more upset about it mom
or dad do you have siblings he's kind of
the mediator I understood how old are
you and how old is your brother look I
think you're on your path I'm really
proud of you stay strong on this here's
why you're doing a huge favor for your
parents not just yourself if you
actually succumbed and lived your life
based on what they wanted you would end
up resenting them and having a bad
relationship so instead you're gonna
have some friction now but you're gonna
have a much better relationship later so
what would you suggest to kind of when
everything goes back to normal for the
people that are scared they won't be
able to adjust fast enough to their
routines and their lifestyle before over
19 I would remind them that they didn't
think they could adjust a Cove in 19 and
here we are three weeks later and
they're adjusted yeah yeah right I mean
you know so this must be a nightmare for
you right because getting out of the
house is the best and now you're like
[ __ ] are you are you taking advantage of
modern technology and things like this
and just consuming and like building
community and just yeah listen listen
let me give you a very good piece of
advice you'll feel a lot of compassion
for your parents I know it's crazy but
but you know this and I know this where
they grew up and how they grew up
[ __ ] up [ __ ] yeah like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
you know and like if you if you actually
are empathetic to them I really think it
will help you be happier too and I mean
that and don't do it just cuz I'm saying
like really take a step back and be like
look this was their reality mmm
they grew up in a better they grew up in
outer space compared to where we grew up
yeah really you know like you they did
how old are your parents they grew up in
a [ __ ] outer space they did see the
world differently they didn't have this
opportunity and they might have some
resentment that they didn't and trying
to impose that on you but that's not
because they're mean
it's because that's how life works
mm-hmm you really need to think about
this it's gonna help you a lot I'm
telling you running away from it is
gonna be fine
and you'll have short-term happiness but
I'm telling you there's a way to combat
this that's sustainable so there could
be a lot more happiness I mean it and
I'm sure you're I'm sorry I would you
know deep down you know how your parents
love you this is what they think is
right they don't want you to be
miserable
they just genuinely believe it's right
they do they think they're helping you
they love you they're they they're based
on fear which makes a lot of sense where
they grew up
mmm-hmm you're not you're fearless I
you're welcome I would also even tell
you that maybe even guilt would help you
you feeling guilty that you were blessed
with fearlessness and growing up in
America and they were and they were
given fear or maybe they were
conditioned maybe your mom was exactly
you but she just had the luck of the
draw of being born in the Soviet Union
and you had the luck of the draw being
grown up in America I mean if you're
combating that you know you know like if
you go with that all of a sudden it
makes their feedback feel a little bit
different
okay thank you have I started my
Instagram and tic toc videos all very
recently you can go ahead and just check
out my page on Instagram I really
appreciate it I will and I will ask
everybody do that I do think tick tock
could really work for you but I'm not
but I'm not letting you off the hook on
this robotic answer on this last little
part yeah listen to me it's going to
help you a lot just like really lean
into being empathetic to where they're
coming from you know like you know how
they got there yeah this is a classic
classic immigrant story for so many of
us Russians Asians Indians like it's so
real and though and and most kids you
know there's the there's the way of like
listen you're I already can tell and
even just the way you were wrapping up
the call like you're gonna be fine cuz
you're too strong-willed and you're just
gonna go [ __ ] do and you're gonna
show I mean you're gonna win I believe
that I actually believe that but when
you win how you win is gonna be
important not just the fact that you won
and you control that you can approach
this very differently you can be the
bigger person even though you're the
younger person you could do you think
you do you think you do you think you
can or do you think you're just
appeasing me we're wrapping up here and
that's okay right yeah yeah you know you
know like it's okay like and my my
parents worked me like a dog you know
like in click you know like it's
you know there's there's there's all
sorts of versions there's all sorts of
things but you have the control you you
have it you have the rest of your life
in front of you you were given the
blessings of like their risk that they
took you you can be the bigger person
they don't have to be everybody thinks
their parents have to do it right as if
that's the rule you can do it right
which then may turn them to doing it
right which is also going to help you
all right thank you take care all right
interesting [ __ ]
I hope that helped a lot of people
that's a super duper duper duper duper
duper duper duper duper duper common
theme for so many people immigrants and
non-immigrants parents expectations
versus your reality and you kind of
really really really figure it out and
yes one person said man is it that bad
to be from the so being yes Martin
people don't understand what that regime
was people were getting murdered people
go to jail for 20 years anti-semitism
was insanity people were sad go look at
every picture of every person in the
Soviet Union from 1945 to 1985 you'll
just see no smiles yes it was that bad
let's keep it going
Oh Gary what's good bro yeah so what
what kind of content like I won't
provide value to the audience's as I
create the content right so I don't know
if I should just and
I teach people how to cut hair or just
show me cutting hair at the same time
talking about my product
can I have my personality in the content
within it you know of course your
personality is the only differentiator
here you know you know you can have
everybody that's good at cutting hair is
good at cutting here yeah the the only
difference you have is your personality
yeah like talk about Batman Batman well
you're wearing a Batman shirt yeah so
but you know yes the answer is the
answer is yes to everything
yes other peoples yes yours yes
personality yes technicality yes yes yes
yes yes yes any time you think should I
post this put a little Gary on your
shoulder you know that [ __ ] angel you
know right right here I'm gonna I'm
gonna make I'm gonna make a little toy
and put on every one shoulder actually a
t-shirt team I want to make a t-shirt
where's a little picture of me and it
just says yes Gustin you got that little
shirt plain t-shirt little [ __ ] the
face of me and just yes and I just want
people [ __ ] weird that and I think
that that's the game yes yes yes okay
other things so strict with me like just
wouldn't let me go at the house no
friends no social contact she was too
scared for me to go outside so she kid
me inside you know with videogames I was
bit crazy at the time because I was like
you know I didn't have any people
interact with so that was me so
basically what I did was I try to be the
smartest person in school and I don't
know so I became like valedictorian high
school recently graduating high school
Crona where is mr. Stoker I don't hang
worried about it you know but yeah like
just being like laced with something if
you were to tell me like you're wrong I
would just take you so offensive you
know there's no no reason you know and
it makes sense if your mom was so
authoritative that means that you've got
built up in that environment and so that
makes sense that you value other
people's opinions because your mom's
dictatorship became
your framework that makes a lot of sense
to me yeah that's okay yeah yeah I could
tell you right now I could tell you
right now just on video I think you have
a great natural human personality I feel
I find you very comfortable on video and
interacting with me I think you'll do
great with people okay
are you feel comfortable around people
yeah because you're insecure
yeah that's why no we're gonna fix it
right we're gonna start right now I got
a secret for you you ready I'll tell you
brother
everybody else sucks too so that's it
bro don't [ __ ] like if they say you
you're not cool you're not good-looking
then say they're not smart if they say
that you're not smart then you can say
they're not funny if they say that
you're you're poor you can say they're
spoiled like everybody else sucks bro
okay all right but do you understand
yeah I understand like like the second
somebody hurts you just convert that
energy hurt them back in your head you
don't even have to be mean it's a little
choppy but let's keep it talking cuz
this is a powerful to conversation I'm
nice to them like they like talk so much
[ __ ] about me but at the end of the day
I'm like you know what maybe there's
something's going out with them like
maybe maybe it's not me maybe it's maybe
it's their family maybe they thought
stick him maybe they're just mad for no
reason maybe I don't know too many
maybes for me to just assume something
about them I [ __ ] love you facts do I
know what you mean it's my religion
being being kind to somebody that's mean
to you is the [ __ ] ultimate strength
yeah people think that you're soft
people I care you're soft you let people
take advantage of you
no I know yeah no I don't I don't care
what they're saying I don't care if they
stole money for me that means they stole
money for me one time yeah it's true you
steal money for me it's the biggest
mistake of your life because I'm worth a
lot more than what you took mm-hmm all
right so what's the problem
the problem is that I don't know whether
I'm like whether I'm a business person
or on cuz my mom like my grandpa had a
business my uncle has a business but mom
has a business businesses I know like
the business world I helped they created
businesses right but at the same time I
grew up being a student so I'm like like
for example let me give you an example
so I watched your content for like about
a year and then there's a there's a
point and where I watched it one of your
videos and said that
stop being a student and stop just
learning like start doing and that's
when it got to me because I was just
learning and learning and learning like
I was in school nor me instead of
actually putting into work so it took me
a year to realize that good your [ __ ]
child most people don't realize that in
their entire life I'm 18 actually so
yeah I know what you are you're a
[ __ ] child you just told me you're a
Jew at high school I know you're again
your [ __ ] child's bro yeah a lot you
have a hundred years ahead of you you're
part of the generation that's gonna live
to 120 that's what I'd be telling your
mom uncle your friends who gives a [ __ ]
you're right okay [ __ ] it's just really
hard not to like I don't know it's very
easy to understand why you have a mom
that dictated a very strict
infrastructure on you so you valued her
opinion which translates to you valuing
everyone's opinion that's your answer
I'll save you time yes well guess what
now you're you're young enough you're
listening to the right things we're
hanging out here hopefully this is a
stepping stone and you need a hundred
thousand other stepping stones and then
you'll reap train your brain and like
it's like cutting hair you get a new
haircut if you shaved your head you
a different haircut you're now gonna
think about it differently you're
changing your mind I can see it I you've
already got it in you yeah it's just
natural is it soon as I started watching
you everything you said everything you
said I was tiny you're the guy that I
need to be listening to because you're
telling me things that I don't like like
we're at the same time he's our stuff
you need to be telling me in order me
you can feel that Kirk's rut it's right
for you it's uncomfortable because I'm
poking at holes but the same token you
know there's truth there and you can
tell that it's coming from a good place
and that's what made it attractive to
you yes because you were you're so kind
like your personality itself like you're
you're a nice person
so any hate towards me you know hey I
have conviction to your point like I
like I like the game like like a lot of
people listen a lot of people come to me
and I carried it and I'm like man this
person's for 29 years has been given
advice this one way and and that's why
they're not happy
so I'm when I look like a dick I'm just
trying to cut some [ __ ] out I'm going in
deep I'm making myself vulnerable I'm
letting people think I'm a dick I'm
taking on the pain of judgment from
others to help that single person cuz a
million people watch that video and
you're like that guy's a dick on
Instagram and I'm like [ __ ] like I'm
taking those [ __ ] hits to help that
one person my reputation to half the
world is going in a bad place I have to
be patient for 25 years to be fully
understood
I'm taking that loss for that one person
yeah yes yeah I saw mommy videos and she
doesn't believe anything that I tell her
about like being eyes you know like you
gotta think long-term my short-term and
I saw her your videos because understand
but I don't you know it's like the way
what did she say she said she said she
doesn't know how to stuff the stuff that
I'm talking about but I understand that
maybe her life wasn't as educated as as
mines maybe it was a circumstantial so
wait you show her the video
and her reaction is what she was like
alright I'm gonna start doing it I had
can you help me because that's good like
she's transnational yeah she's that
makes sense to me my father is - like
it's what's him when you come from zero
you keep it's hard to go up here yeah
she didn't have the luxury that you and
I had dudes yes yeah because I was
middle class and go to school but then
I'm like school I don't feel like it's
for me because like good it's like it I
feel like I'm like it's just the system
is not right for me you know so break
the system and that's why I just
respected yeah so great so everything
bro I I like it bike if you were a stock
if you were like a stock I would invest
in you I hear everything that I like
yeah as I stared with clarity this is
great do you think you have the work
ethic the work ethic yes I actually work
to construct you since I was 12 bro
you're [ __ ] bro you're a [ __ ] like
ah your [ __ ] Amazon I want to I want
to invest in you you're gonna win bro do
me one favor remember this forever
kindness is the ultimate strength
kindness - bro I cry during Lion King I
cry in every movie I'm sensitive as [ __ ]
yeah
sensitivity is great it's why you have
so much emotional intelligence yeah like
like like like when I got married people
were just talking like so much like I
can I say it's not [ __ ] to me like why
are you getting married are you doing
that like I'm making decisions based on
what I think is right like how do you
this is something like people judge you
that they don't even understand we broke
it you have to understand you look at
them and be like Hector Sally
Rick Tom you know Salvador I love you
for saying this thank you
you go have fun and - you're 35 for me I
wanted to be married at 18 I fell in
love
like I understand what you're saying
thank you thank you Sal for saying that
now you go worry about your life yeah
okay like you know like see say thank
you yeah tamo go live your [ __ ] life
all right Sal you don't like getting
married 18 you go [ __ ] hook up with
chicks until you're 40 Mazel Tov go have
fun
good yeah I'm happy for you what makes
me happy is this brother do not put
other people's opinions on a pedestal
when they're not living your life yes
yes tell them to live their [ __ ] life
okay then by the way listen to me listen
know what's not being mean what it's
like you said thank you yeah
you didn't say [ __ ] you Sal get the [ __ ]
in my business I don't respect the way
you bang chicks [ __ ] you you're a piece
of [ __ ] you said thank you Sal Palma I
appreciate it cama this was this was
what was right for me I fell in love and
I was okay with it you know our
grandparents all got married these ages
kama kama I'm so excited that you're
gonna have lots of fun in college and
date and go to the big city like I know
tell you that's why I'm regurgitating it
so you know what I'm talking about that
I know what to find out what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about
you've been even doing it for a good
bout a year I've been texting you on
Instagram saying you are always right
listen I'm not always right but I'm open
I'm always coming from a very clear
point of view that's right for me
I'm not necessarily always right for
everybody else but there are things that
everybody can take that can help them I
don't want anybody to be me or do it
like me I want everybody to do it that
works for them but there are things like
kindness and empathy that are right
brother sensitivity is the biggest
strength I have I cried every day until
I was 15 I cried when the Jets lost I
cried when when when somebody's feelings
got hurt I cried when people picked on
other kids and it didn't make me feel
nice because I could feel that kid that
later
that later became wire
was right about tick-tock why I
predicted tea with Gary Vee 10 years ago
but my sensitivity is my [ __ ]
superpower okay it's a gift
yeah okay compassion and sympathy is a
gift
bro I cried when [ __ ] the lion Kings
flying and dad cartoon guy cried in the
theatre with my [ __ ] friends like hot
chicks from high school sitting right
there cried cried yeah okay yeah I'm
trying to like understand everything
okay so yeah it's makes it go into like
the right way of thinking the right
things I promise you this the next time
one of your clown friends makes fun of
you or has an opinion tell them I
appreciate it Sal Hector but Gary B
thinks I'm awesome and you're a [ __ ]
[ __ ] so there you go bro I think I
think way better than cool I think
you're a [ __ ] great kid I'm like
sticking on this call because I want to
be with you I think you're lovely and
kind and capable and have all the
[ __ ] elements of having a
tremendously impactful life okay
so just just thank you thank you so much
Garson you know what's interesting about
this show is like you know it's funny
like it's funny to like go through the
process of communicating your truth
what do you mean meaning like I've
always known who the [ __ ] I was you know
and like throwing out I'm gonna buy the
Jets is like an easy peacocking like I'm
not [ __ ] around here move but it's
not deep it's a gay I'm gonna buy a
sports team it's actually douchey some
of the [ __ ] that's happening here like
I've never articulated the the the
judgment I get at scale for trying to
help somebody that comes across that I'm
audacious or rude I'm a human that
doesn't feel good when you know you're
up to something
and people dismiss you as bad right
especially when you're sensitive a nice
yeah I'm surprised I don't know how you
handle it
like that I can't do that it's it's kind
of like your gift is your curse you
becomes your domain I can't [ __ ] spin
a bunch of handlebars around one shot
[ __ ] it i watch your videos I'm like I'd
skin my need not be unconscious and be
sad that's scary to me I'm not doing
those flip [ __ ] [ __ ] spin and so I
can jump off a [ __ ] curb everything
you know everyone's themselves but like
people are just so surface level they're
not paying attention to what I'm doing
out here
and that's why tea with Gary B has been
so powerful I definitely think that I've
pulled I pulled another layer of the
onion away and I think people are seeing
it I really believe that yeah people are
definitely saying they don't even
[ __ ] know Dustin they do not know
nobody watching now understands I'm not
[ __ ] around here I'm winning the
whole [ __ ] thing the whole thing
nobody else me I'm the guy I know it I
know it too let's keep it going
hi Gary
how are you good good okay so I'm a
makeup artist and I guess I'll just give
you a little backstory of kind of I
guess I'm a first generation college
student so my mom's from Mexico and
college was basically forced on me like
I'm going to college it's happening
you're checking the bar I don't have to
go yeah I'm going I'm going for it and
so I decided to go into pharmaceutical
research so chemistry biology I hate it
I just absolutely hated it I didn't like
watching bacteria girl I didn't like
going to labs I didn't like writing the
reports it was just it wasn't for me so
of course trying to drop out of college
wasn't a thing either
cuz my mom's not gonna let me drop out
of college so I just stopped going to
classes I got myself in so much that and
it was all private loans because my
family didn't know where to get it from
we
didn't have money for me to go to
college so I'm still dealing with that
um but I finally was like I'm not gonna
Klout classes anymore I started playing
makeup practicing makeup when I was just
setting in my dorm and people started
showing interest like hey can you do my
makeup can you get my wedding can you do
this can you do that and I was like I
don't have any experience I don't like
know what I'm doing other than my own
makeup so I finally took my mom like
sorry mom I'm gonna go to school for
makeup so I came back to the cities and
when she said oh you know I didn't go
over well she's like well how are you
gonna make a career out of that how are
you going to is there gonna make you
enough money you're already so much
money and why don't you just finish ba
ba ba I'm like mom I barely made it
through a first year biology let her
look I didn't make it to a chemistry
course because I was like forget it
I hate it so she I just kind of told her
I was like I'm so sorry but I'm just
gonna do this and mostly howdy in the
cosmic C's in the cosmetology world - so
she already knows how much you have to
work your ass off in the industry so
everything's like are you sure yep you
have to work your ass off in every
industry yeah yeah so I mean I want to
be successful like I gotta keep going
awesome
so I love everything about the debt
pisses me off but keep going yeah me too
but yeah so I went to school for
multimedia makeup so I basically can
turn somebody really cute or I can turn
him into a zombie in two seconds you
know really so yeah it's really fun I
run into the issue that when I went to
school because Minnesota doesn't you
don't need a license to freelance I
found myself in the bridal industry so I
went with an agency for a while when I
first got out of school and 2016 and I
worked for an agency for a couple years
and I realized I'm like I'm only making
about 50% of the hundred percent work
that I'm doing so I'm like I think I can
do this on myself yeah I'm like you're
basically running a credit card like I
know how to do that too um so I went
over and I started my own Bridal
business um so I do weddings as the
seasons come along
um and yeah so the issue that I run into
is that since Minnesota doesn't require
you to have a certificate or a license
through Board of Cosmetology I can't
work in a salon because they're ran
through Board of Cosmetology
I knew that aesthetician or cosmetology
license so I lose that aspect of having
a clientele being able to come somewhere
regularly so go to them or oh yeah yeah
I absolutely do that I just I see a lot
of you build a real quick okay real
quick I know where you're going so real
quick
yeah just like some people think like
your mom that college was the only path
to making money and you were like go
[ __ ] yourselves I can do this I
understand that salons are a feeder for
clientele and and finding new clientele
so is [ __ ] tick tock and Instagram
yeah there's nothing you're gonna
there's nothing you're gonna say right
now of the values of the license that
isn't arbitrage around by you making
creative on tik-tok and Instagram
nothing absolutely let's thank you for a
second if you're if you're saying
absolutely to that like I want to put a
nail in that coffin like you know the
answer yeah is so well they're trying to
pass the law and work because they're
trying to regulate as well because yeah
Board of Cosmetology is coming for
Bridal I know what they're doing right
because they know it's you can mean
right [ __ ] Minnesota the cold is really
a pain
yes [ __ ] other than Minnesota rocker the
eSports team I own in Minnesota [ __ ]
Minnesota and [ __ ] meaning if they
pass some law that [ __ ] you don't worry
about what other things and other people
are doing
nobody's going in nobody nobody's going
to the salon right now it's [ __ ]
COBIT light okay
that was gonna be my part of my question
here is because I rely so heavily on
clientele that's where my work comes
from I have to be
the person interaction and so my biggest
focus right now is I have my Instagram
account that's I don't know if it's
linked or not but it's my professional
page so I create I obviously post my
clients I post my weddings I do special
effects you know just dabble and
everything just because I like my makeup
but I found that on social media because
makeup is being the YouTuber makeup it's
everywhere you turn you seeing a new
make a new ID I knew this that and
makeup artists working makeup artist I
feel like they get lost in social media
over the youtubers and them doing their
Omega versus us going out or they don't
do much they don't get lost okay because
I see a lot of I see a lot of companies
focus around the youtubers a lot of a
lot more recognition because they're
much bigger audiences yeah but they're
personnel they were build very quickly
and my personality behind the camera you
know instead of okay I'm gonna apply my
blush here because like you know bug you
and probably know how to do your makeup
at this point by watching all this like
videos on the feed but so I had start
another another Instagram because I
don't want to be the make working makeup
artist with a thousand selfie it's like
oh I do my people's makeup but it's only
pictures of me because those ones get
more interaction they're like oh you're
really like you know I love your makeup
love it well I'm like okay well why
don't you go say it like I like you to
commenting on and letting me know what
you think of client makeup because
that's what I actually like to do so I
you know get that you need a lot of my
selfies and why well it's just I don't I
like clients being able to come to my
page and see my word but you can but you
can mix it yeah
I had a good mix it's just I was I just
seen more of my face my face I'm like
this is not what I want to pull that she
didn't come to my page so do a different
mix okay like what was your mix me or
how it with COBIT how do I go about that
because they just accepted us another
almost three weeks out and I can't do
client so did you just do because I
started YouTube I gave in I didn't you
to doing my makeup just showing other
makeup Heather you know what you go by
Heather another marine Heather Heather
well I mean it's Heather Miriam but you
know Heather you know how your mom you
know how your mom put College on a
pedestal and it [ __ ] you up you're
putting influencer dynamics on a
pedestal of an ideology of how you see
the world and it's [ __ ] you up I know
and I know that and I know that yeah I
just wanna be like that youtuber that's
like and I know I know my value I know
my worth of like who I am as an artist
because I know you do
guess whatever I want to make garage
sale videos to help people learn how to
make from zero to a hundred dollars but
most of my business friends thinks it
makes me look bad and people won't take
my real business advice serious but I
don't give a [ __ ] what they think you're
you're you're repeating your mom's
mistake on your ownself your mom put
school on such a ideological platform
because of the grind that she went
through and didn't want that for her
wonderful daughter but she made you go
into debt on something that brought you
no value and it was the wrong move you
have judged these non technically sound
makeup artists who are fluff who've
amassed millions of followers on YouTube
and in your judgment of them you've held
yourself back from the growth I promise
you
through people's trash doesn't
underestimate the fact that I have
accomplished everything that I've
accomplished you taking a selfie that
you look good in doesn't make you
doesn't undermine your actual work your
ideology let's talk about that let's
talk about that yeah cuz it's a great
question thank you you just helped a lot
of people even though you don't like it
no I want you to be happy and happy over
business success period and the story no
debate the question becomes why don't
you like it to me that's the most
important part of this conversation
either no I want you to be happy and I
don't and I don't give a [ __ ] if you
make less money have less opportunities
but you're asking me you know for a cut
we're talking and it's under the guise I
assume of you having more success ok
happiness but actually you know you know
gets scary when everything shuts down
and you want to diversify your income
offshore right but like here's the real
question
why like do you do you feel like being
valued for being pretty undermines your
intellect
are you actually insecure of how you
look do you not want to be associated
with people that you disrespect how they
handle their lives there's a lot of real
[ __ ] questions how they're under there
yeah it's not as simple as I don't want
to I want to know why I just want to
push my workouts more so do more you
know street so post post three times a
day with two works and one you and oh by
the way you talking about which coffee
you like you humanizing yourself will
lead to so much more opportunity which
will lead to people more seeing your
work I'm tricking [ __ ] into being
better people by disguising myself as a
business person the [ __ ] do you think's
going on here your work will get more
life I know I get in my head so much
it's just I know exactly well I don't
know exactly where I want to end up but
I know my turn
like okay this is where I know because I
know the steps I know what needs to
happen it's just I want to get there in
you anything you want to get ahead I
know you want to get there based on an
ideology you created instead of actually
getting there you value the ideology
more than actually getting there I'm
telling you you do you know what's even
scarier you you you were valuing other
people's opinions I thought I know I
just I that's the most frustrating part
it's when you know your flaws or you
know what's your issue and it's just
like you can't get past that because
what you're doing is making you happy
and it's like well those other things
are still there they're still lingering
there school it's like you're getting me
like I know what I'm supposed to be
doing don't pay attention people which I
my opinions of other people might forget
it like I already told my mom like you
know like my mom out of all people like
all right bye see you you know more
importantly more importantly I think
there's an underlining judgment you have
towards those other people because you
were blessed with talent
so you're judging other people which
then makes you susceptible to being
judged do you know why I don't struggle
with judgment because I'm not judging
anybody else and then you're spending
time looking at their channels and their
posts and [ __ ] judging the people for
liking them like creative fantasy like
crazy makeup it's a complete art like I
love everything that they do it's more
of the the side of when I have a client
sit down I chair like oh are you a
youtuber too or do you do your mate like
how do you do your heather I've
successfully operated and built two
major businesses through blood sweat and
tears and a fuckload of smarts I have
been one of the wiser more strategic
investors
I have systematically been correct about
so many consumer
Ren's over the last 20 years at the
highest levels in the world and almost
everybody rolls up at me and like you
know two friends were left and I Gary B
and the other person who's this is like
oh that's that motivational speaker on
Instagram I put nothing but [ __ ] w's
on the board for 20 years and I'm the
motivational person on Instagram he's
that funny guy that sells trash on
tick-tock
that's literally what people say who
gives a [ __ ] if you know who you are
what the [ __ ] does it matter you're way
way way off on this you're way off on us
in a real good way because you're super
close I'm pumped you're way off and
close that's why this is fun I know but
you're close you're close you just need
to drop this one I'm a motivational
speaker to 90% of the people it makes me
throw up in my mouth and want to go to
sleep I'm a motivational speaker I'm
[ __ ] an executor at the highest
levels who happens to be motivated and
optimistic you're not a [ __ ] youtuber
you're [ __ ] big-time talented makeup
artist who happens to make [ __ ]
YouTube videos enough who gives a [ __ ]
what Sara from Minneapolis thinks when
she sits in your [ __ ] chair right
[ __ ] Sara I have another question you
had done an interview with Sam par and
he had asked you about other businesses
that you're interested in or upcoming
businesses or like e-commerce or
whatever it was but you had said men's
mega you're interested in men's makeup
and you didn't get to touch back on it
at all and that when I heard I was like
oh my god he's probably gonna answer
your makeup question like I was super
pumped and obviously you guys ran out of
time but so I'm out of time now for this
episode as well but I'm not gonna do it
to you again let me just look at my
schedule [ __ ] okay so I believe that
men's makeup straight men not the
incredible communities that are
alternative straight men are going to
actually wear makeup in the world and I
think it's gonna be at scale somewhere
in the next 10 to 15 to 20 years
I believe it fully 100
said I believe that will be true okay I
mean I don't see why not you know you
got a you don't like it you know it's
it's no no I'm not talking about I'm not
talking about some of the places that
all have dabbled in to like cover up I'm
talking I shadow I'm talking like me
having like a [ __ ] lightning bolt on
my cheek every day I'm talking real [ __ ]
I'm talking I'm talking lipstick okay I
think if you look carefully in tick-tock
oh yeah I think if you look carefully in
tick-tock culture the the 14 15 16 13
twelve-year-old girls the guys that
they're attracted to are clearly in that
direction the e boys are in that
direction
long hair highlights you know you know
finger you know nail polish lips like
it's it's already happened I don't
predict I don't guess it's already
happened now it just needs to play out
social acceptance I'm like dating when I
told my friends was gonna happen you
know you know I love that Calvin Knight
believes that screen shoot this real
quick for me Dustin because that's gonna
go in the archives because Calvin
Knights gonna [ __ ] take a huge loss
just like all my friends had said online
dating wouldn't happen just like all my
friends had said nobody was gonna go on
Facebook that are insane in college just
like all my friends that said I was
wrong about tick-tock to musically
people don't get it I'm never gonna be
wrong because I don't guess I just
watched so much carefully I listen so
much more i interrupt people I get that
but nobody on [ __ ] earth is listening
more than me I'm telling you that right
the [ __ ] now I'm in the [ __ ] game
when it comes to listening of course
there's other people that are listening
as much as me but like I'm in the
[ __ ] game and it's already [ __ ]
people you already know and I do the
same thing I'm terrible I try to catch
myself like Heather let them finish
their thought like even though you
already have the answer and their
solution and this and that it's like
it's saving the clients when they sit
down in my chair like oh well I had this
I'm like I already I can I can see
girlfriend like I got you by the way you
know it's like by the way I'm sure you
already had the answer I get it I get it
somebody said Eric Thompson said strong
John Wayne and Clint Eastwood is gone
it's actually not gone I think they both
coexist
I actually think like old
cool men like Harden pale a tough guy I
think that's emerging too like there's a
lot of things happening you know you
know it's just it's just such
interesting Heather listen to me you're
so [ __ ] close but you're so [ __ ]
wrong and it's really exciting it's
really exciting he goes he's like
alright we'll be ready to sit there and
like no he's not gonna [ __ ] you I
was like I don't wanna [ __ ] I was
like just like this is what you're doing
wrong because like I know I'm so close
and I'm just like I need someone to like
I mean not about it right there but like
we're human yeah we're humans we're
humans affirmation you know you know is
a real powerful thing you are so [ __ ]
close you just need to know that your
mom was wrong about her ideology about
college and you're wrong on your
judgement of youtubers and social media
people okay well I'm so for my I had I'm
try not to take your time back because I
started another page because I was in
the idea of keep my selfies on one page
and my work on another do I just keep it
all on the handle that I have okay yep
oh you I just I mean stop [ __ ] you
stop shooting stop [ __ ] on other
people and your dream of how you should
be looked upon as a professional and
start [ __ ] living your honest full
life on it yeah awesome I gotta go okay
thank you so much you're working mother
all right
[ __ ] man I don't know dust this might
little bit of Jesus this was good there
was some real [ __ ] fire yeah there
was some real stuff the Russian girl had
their you know like right like there was
some real stuff the dude from the
18-year old like there's I got the post
at a team meets get to work it was a
[ __ ] fire episode wine Tex calm you
know if you don't sign up for it I'm
gonna kick you out of having the ability
to watch this scream I'm done with you
we're not friends
it's over
finished see ya that's real and the Olin
challenge my auction is running up on
Saturday tomorrow it's over so if you've
not bought your raffle tickets please
please do that now here is what I'm
offering on the island challenge love
you I am giving away the ultimate
garyvee experience how should I go okay
over the last week or so I've been a gem
with my friend Michael Rubin and helping
out on this all-in challenge that I am
accepting right now but all-in challenge
calm please go there we are challenging
some of the greatest artists
entertainers athletes in the world to
provide a ridiculous all-time experience
or one of their most iconic items in
their collection to help raise money to
help feed the hungry during this
ridiculous time and so now I have to put
up my auction
so my auction the ultimate garyvee
experience here we go I'm gonna go off
the top of the head and you can go on
all-in challenge calm to go bid on this
I am giving away okay you get to in the
course of the year you will go garage
sailing with me and film trash talk also
you can get a workout with me and Mike
the Conti so I know a lot of you pay
attention to that part of my world also
we're gonna go to Wine Library and do a
$25,000 shopping spree that's right I'm
gonna pay my dad well I'm gonna donate
we're gonna pay my dad 25,000 so $25,000
shopping spree at Wine Library I will
walk through the whole store with you
tell you the war stories and you'll buy
a bunch of a wine beer liquor whatever
you want food we are going to go to a
Jets game together
you're gonna tailgate with me I never do
this when I give away Jets tickets I
never let the person sit with me so you
will sit with me during the Jets game I
won't talk to you during the game I'm
completely focused but you'll get that
so the ultimate Jets experience tailgate
full game with me as well also I'm going
to give you one week play at Vayner
media so this is for you and a plus-one
by the way so the two tickets the will
be some plus ones we'll do some just me
and you depending on what is one full
week at vaynermedia getting consulting
and business advice from team Gary Vee
and me for the entire week hanging out
in the pit where the shows done you're
gonna be a guest of my podcast we're
going to do a wine dinner for you and
have your friends at hunt fish club in
New York City and I'm gonna fly you all
paid plus 1 to 3 of my keynotes and
we'll work on those details the ultimate
garyvee experience I hope you bid on it
I hope you get involved I hope we raise
a lot of money to help people that need
it all so what's so fun about the o-line
challenge is you get to challenge people
to be in it I am gonna challenge all the
Boehner sports athletes I expect you in
there so that is number one number two
I'm gonna go with ooh you know what
Tim Berlin the super producer who's
completely lighting up Instagram
Timbaland the super producer I'm calling
you out and finally I got one the
Undertaker
one of the great wrestlers of all time
please join the challenge everybody go
to all in challenge calm please support
this the experiences are gonna be nuts
we've been working bleeding out of the
eyeballs for the last week putting this
all together you're gonna be blown away
what you're about to see on social media
hashtag all and challenge please check
it out and please go to your favorite
celebrities athletes and entertainers
and leave hashtag all-in challenge to
get them involved the all and challenge
please take it